l'une des grandes difficultés des débats
c'est que souvent quand on est dans un
débat on est un peu en mode soul garde à
vous entendre on sera à voir nous
défendre nous-mêmes à défendre notre
clan et en particulier on a l'impression
d'être potentiellement attaqué à chaque
erreur que l'on pourrait dire et ça
malheureusement ce sont de très
mauvaises conditions de débats puisque
ces risques on risque de partir au quart
de tour puisque on attend ça avoir du
mal à être bienveillant et puisque on va
du coup avoir tendance à ne pas dire
exactement ce qu'on pense mais peut-être
davantage à dire ceux qui défend notre
position pour sortir de cette logique
malsaine les semble indispensable de
faire attention à ce que je vais appeler
la sécurité émotionnelle au cours d'un
débat
c'est à dire idéalement il faut que
chacun se sente libre de dire ce qu'il
pense y compris s'il pense que ce qu'il
dit est probablement une erreur
je pense que c'est quelque chose
d'important à encourager globalement la
bienveillance envers des erreurs mais
plus globalement cette ambiance de
débats où l'erreur n'est pas tout de
suite cassé d'un coup de façon assez
violente et méchante mais plutôt là
l'erreur et reçu de façon bienveillante
donc que tu un point on va juste laissé
affaires sont exprimés à l'est la
laisser aller au bout du raisonnement
les questionner gentiment avec
bienveillance tels ou tels fondements de
son raisonnement pour que la personne
soit vraiment amener à réfléchir à ce
qu'elle a dit est qu'elles ne se sentent
pas juger et en particulier sept sont
jugés à risque de sentir le besoin de se
défendre immédiatement
malheureusement quand on débat
instinctivement on a beaucoup de mauvais
réflexes qui vont aggraver le sentiment
de sécurité émotionnelle a tendance à
mettre les gens en difficulté même sans
le vouloir
typiquement en le reprenant dès qu'on
peut techniquement en insistant sur des
choses sans que l'autre comprennent
pourquoi c'est important ou typiquement
en ayant un essaim certains excès de
confiance exprimée que par son année que
cette confiance en tant que tel mais on
a parfois tendance à s'exprimer avec
tellement d'assurance qu'on donne
l'impression que penser différemment et
forcément erronées voire pire encore est
forcément stupide ou débile et dans ce
genre de situation bas les
interlocuteurs ne sont pas mon style mon
sentiment de sécurité émotionnelle
puisqu'ils ont vraiment l'impression que
s'ils disent quelque chose de travers
ils seront traités de quelque chose
comme subsides ou débile où on leur
reprochera leur mauvaise intention
bref si on n'y prête pas attention on a
tendance à mettre plus tôt l'autre dans
une situation d'insécurité émotionnel ce
qui favorise absolument pas la qualité
des débats
en particulier le gros problème de
twitter c'est sans doute cette
insécurité émotionnelle qui ne fait que
sur twitter dès qu'on dit quelque chose
n'importe qui peut réagir de manière
ultra violente et ça peut finir en chips
thorn et du coup globalement sur twitter
c'est encore plus important de faire
gaffe à cette sécurité émotionnelle
par exemple en évitant les débats clash
période par exemple aux mutants les
personnes que l'on trouve trop virulente
et qui nous crée une insécurité
émotionnel
donc il semble qu'une partie importante
au débat surtout eu des débats sur des
sujets assez chaud ça doit être de créer
un sentiment de confort et de sécurité
émotionnelle pour tous les participants
et malheureusement c'est un truc qui est
extrêmement déficient d'habitude tu au
moins à titre personnel c'est clairement
quelque chose que je fais encore très
très mal j'ai tendance à trop souvent
coupé les gens au mieux de leur
réflexion parce qu'ils ont dit un truc
qui me semble très problématique
alors qu'il semble peut-être préférable
de laisser les gens parler à laisser les
gens aller au bout de leur raisonnement
être sûr que ils ont expliqué les choses
telles qu il voulait les avoir expliqué
de la meilleure manière possible et les
accompagner dans cette réfection vont
créer un sentiment de confort et de
sécurité émotionnelle et ensuite
peut-être commencer à petit à petit
questionner certains bouts amener les
gens à mieux réfléchir mais surtout
éviter de les bloquer voilà c'est encore
quelque chose sur lequel il faut que je
travaille
bref bonne partie de mieux débattre ça
semble correspondre à faire en sorte
qu'il est vraiment un climat dans lequel
les gens peuvent débattre sereinement et
vraiment s'exprimer sans avoir peur de
se faire moquer ou violemment critiqué
et finalement tout ça ce n'est pas si
différent de l'apprentissage des
mathématiques
quand on apprend les maths
malheureusement il arrive trop souvent
qu'on soit entouré de gens qui soit
beaucoup trop du aurait beaucoup trop
dans le sarcasme et la moquerie des
erreurs de calcul et ça ça fait que la
plupart des gens sont dégoûtés des
mathématiques et une bonne partition de
la population a même peur des
mathématiques il n'arrivera jamais à
devenir bon mathématique non pas parce
qu'ils ont pas niveau mais parce qu'ils
n'ont plus la motivation et le goût pour
les mathématiques
de la même façon il semble que ce soit
super important dans tout débat surtout
sur des sujets chauds et où l'ailé
important d'avoir des réflexions
collectives
ils sont super important qui n'est pas
d'auto-censure à ce niveau là et que les
gens ne se disent pas je ne vais pas
réfléchir à ça parce qu'on voit encore
se moquer ou me critiquer violemment
c'est pour ça que le scepticisme autour
d'une guerre entre amis à rigoler un
petit peu avec la bonne tendance est
bonne bouffe
c'est quand même ultra important